[Laughter]
[Music]
it's already march and you know what
time it is
it's time to start wrapping up the epic
season that is winter 2021 for it not
because just as we bid farewell to our
friends from the current season we have
a bright future ahead as we take a look
at some of the best anime this spring
2021 so here we are for today's list the
top 10 anime for spring 2021
no sequels no spin-offs just new stuff
that you can look forward to
before we get started i've noticed that
a sizeable portion of people watching my
videos
aren't subscribed let's push that number
up shall we subscribing only requires a
click and a few seconds and doing so
will immensely help the channel and
it will make me happy too now let's
start with the list coming in at the
start is that the world ends with you
the animation
[Music]
okay so i didn't see this one coming
it's been forever since i heard the
title the world ends with you and i got
to admit that i don't have much
experience with the series when it was a
modestly popular video game
i also didn't think that it was popular
enough to warrant an anime this 2021
but the excitement i saw when the
announcement was made totally changed my
mind
so what's the buzz about a protagonist
neku wakes up and discovers that he's
able to read the minds of others thanks
to a black pin that he suddenly
possesses with his newfound power
he gets forced to play the reaper's game
to compete for the ultimate prize that
determines the fate of humanity
it has this stylistic swagger that
represents a really cool and sleek part
of modern japanese culture
personally my standards for video game
adaptations aren't that high thanks to
shows like akiba's trip
persona 5 and the recent sakura wars but
this series looks like it's primed to
turn heads
and come out as one of the better game
adaptations
ninth on the list is mars red no this
has got nothing to do with outer space
no this has nothing to do with mars of
destruction for those of you who don't
know the legendary piece of anime
history instead
mars red takes us back to 1923 where a
world ravaged by vampires awaits a
savior
this savior would come in the form of
the japanese government which creates
code zero
a unit tasked with hunting down these
demonic beings who else better to fight
vampires than their own kind right thus
begins the war between vampires that
will change the course of the world i
found out about this show quite late but
i can't deny that it looks
really stylish it has that gritty
serious anime feel that i remember most
from some hits of yesteryear like
boccano or the more recent 91 days
mars red also happens to be an
adaptation of a stage reading so we can
see how well that medium translates into
[Music]
anime
next in line is way of the house husband
now here's another title that i've been
hearing a lot of good things about the
interesting thing is that after i
decided to read the manga way of the
house husband just blew me away
i didn't expect myself to be that
entertained but this was one amazing
comedy series
basically the plot's about a legendary
yakuza noted for being able to
single-handedly strike down rival gangs
and sowing fear in both police and
criminals alike like any good hero of
legend
our guy tatsu disappears only to
resurface
looking nothing like the feared lord of
the japanese underworld he's vowed to
turn his life around and make an
honest living as a house husband however
tatsu soon finds out that the kitchen
and the supermarket provide a whole new
battlefield one that he's got a long way
to go from conquering misunderstanding
seems to follow this comically serious
ex yakuza in this series that will
surely leave you laughing for hours on
end
if not for the production issues this
series would have been a lot higher on
this list i mean the trailer kind of
looks like a slideshow rather than an
animation but only time will tell how
the audience will fully react to the
full adaptation done this way
let's dive into the world of sci-fi for
the next entry
vivi fluorite ice song re-zero second
season may have ended but we've not seen
the last of tape nagatsuki
yes the author of one of the most
popular isekai's back to pen this new
anime along with eg
umehara from chaos child fame vb
fluorite isong is an original sci-fi
anime set to air this april 2021
here we go on a journey to a theme park
where the human psyche and technology
intertwine
near land taking center stage is vivi an
ai who looks to make people happy
through music
despite the park's struggles the routine
comes crashing down when another ai
matsumoto comes from the future and
warns vivi
about a looming war between ai and
humanity the two of them then set forth
on a quest to correct the bleak future
being an original anime we can only
really judge it based on the trailers
and my impressions basically sum up that
it looks pretty good
and we can all thank wit studio for that
i'm always up for anime with these
aesthetics
and seeing as we just recently got a
pretty nice surprise from a similar
looking original title in decadence i'll
be anticipating this title
i think a lot of you are going to enjoy
this one
[Music]
eighty six
[Music]
86. now here's something that i've been
anticipating ever since i saw the novels
first i've taken an interest in 86
add that to the fact that i'm probably
one of the fewer people who really
enjoyed gimisen some time back and i can
see this anime clicking with me already
this time the story of 86 takes us to
the war-torn republic of san magnolia
after years of battles with its
neighboring nation the republic has
finally turned the conflict around with
a war without casualties or that's what
everybody thought but supposedly
unmanned droids employed to battle are
actually being piloted by people of the
86 sector
these people stripped of their humanity
headed to battle our story revolves
around lena and
shin two individuals whose fate
intertwines within the forsaken sector
of the republic military fiction in
light novels is something that i
personally have a good track record with
so i find myself very excited for 86
given that it's also from a1
i'm pretty sure that a lot of you would
have a general idea of what to expect
overall
86 looks like a pretty nice take on the
valkyria chronicles setting while taking
cues from a world war ii backdrop
now that we're at the halfway mark i'd
like to take a break and thank our
sponsors for this video
expressvpn did you know right that the
shows i've been talking about are being
simulcast on so many different streaming
platforms but what if you're in some
third world country that's not being
supported by these streaming platforms
or simply blocked out of watching your
show because of where you're located
well best boy expressvpn to the rescue
with expressvpn's amazing service
you can connect to so many different
proxy servers from all over the world
i use it just this weekend to watch
hunter hunter which isn't available in
the uk all i had to do was open up
expressvpn and select the united states
server and
boom now i can watch hunter hunter like
dozens of other anime on netflix
say goodbye to the frustrating region
lock messages with your best buddy by
your side
also did you know that you can use
expressvpn for a lot of other things
besides watching anime with expressvpn
by your side you can also access blocked
websites and movie services that aren't
available in your country
expand your media libraries and watch a
lot of hollywood offerings
which is really important seeing as
we've got a lot of blockbusters headed
our way
if you're looking for a vpn to use then
look no further expressvpn blows
everything else out of the water with
its ease of use speed
and pure value for what you're paying if
you want to know how to get started with
expressvpn and get three months for free
just follow the link that i've left you
on the description box or go to
expressvpn.comtube
[Music]
eden zero makes its way into the fifth
spot spring 2021 will also mark the
debut of mashima hero's new working
anime form
eden zero is set to air and it promises
a pretty fun and quirky sci-fi adventure
a departure from his previous works
despite the whole thing looking like a
fairy tale remake or something like that
spending most of his days being raised
by robots
cheeky granbell dreams of greener
pastures countless possibilities
awaiting the world beyond the theme park
and shiki would want nothing but to go
on adventures mundane days would come to
an end when the park receives its first
visitors in the form of rebecca
and happy when tragedy befalls rebecca
and happy take sheiki with them on their
journey through space mashima hero tries
his hand in sci-fi with this all-new
series that promises some of the
author's signatures that includes quirky
action
memorable characters and lots of fan
service space pirates
czech magical cyborgs check cybernetic
dragons check it's a space adventure
like no other
at number four is don't toy with me miss
nagatoro you know that one incident
where it seems that the whole complexion
of your social
standing changes but nagatoro's senpai
case it's the girl stumbling upon his
drawings it seems to have awakened
something within the girl and now she
can't get enough of bullying her senpai
a powerless senpai just can't help but
get roped into her antics and follow
through her pace is this an uneasy
friendship that will be developing
between the two of them or will the guy
continue to endure a life of misery
brought to him by his classmate i've
heard quite a bit about this title when
it was a manga and it's got the
polarizing reception to say the least
it's like a way more serious and for
lack of a better term
sinister version of dakagi-san
nonetheless i'll be anticipating it very
much just to see how it will fare as an
upcoming anime how about you
want to try it out see if it's to your
liking
[Music]
starting our top three countdown is
shaman king
[Music]
we've officially entered remake
territory which
consists of only one title for this list
shaman king for those of you who weren't
around some two decades ago shaman
king's basic premise is basically one
huge
tournament arc featuring spirits and
magical weapons and a main character who
can see ghosts if it's giving you some
serious bleach or solely to vibes well
i'm not surprised the story revolves
around yo asakura a laid-back boy who
makes friends with spirits he finds
himself getting involved in the
high-stakes shaman fight
a tournament featuring shamans all over
the world battling to take the ultimate
crown controlling the great spirit a
being that's so
strong that can grant its partner
world-changing powers the previous anime
deviated a lot from the manga after the
first 20 or so episodes so this remake
should be able to let you experience the
story that never got animated having
read the manga i've got to tell you that
things get pretty
crazy out there if you're someone who
enjoyed the previous series or someone
who wants something similar while
waiting for 2021's bleach
don't miss out on this one
[Music]
our runner-up today is tokyo revengers
time travel
an elusive power that a lot of people
want to have something so impossible in
real world but can open up so many
possibilities that can be seen in media
tokyo revenges is one such story and
given the climate of the industry right
now
i think that it's right for another one
of these life can't get any worse for
dakimichi hanagaki well
actually it can how does having your
ex-girlfriend murdered by the notorious
and ruthless tokyo manji gang sound it's
got to be as heart-wrenching as it can
be all hope isn't lost though however as
our hero finds himself
traveling back in time with a chance to
prevent the worst ending from happening
our protagonist resolves to infiltrate
the gang and climb its ranks to change
the future an immensely popular manga
tokyo avengers finally gets its
much-awaited anime adaptation a tale of
drama and comradeship
tokyo revenge starts airing this april
11th
finally we end with to your eternity i
think that it's not too tight of a
contest to determine the number one most
anticipated new anime this spring season
with a pedigree like the writer of
asylum voice backing it and some amazing
visuals that make the whole thing look
as cinematic as it can be how can it not
be
it seems to have some really strong
thematic appeals too the premise is
quite simple
featuring an alien organism coming to
our planet and being able to learn and
acquire experiences by transforming into
various objects that it comes across
ultimately it hits the jackpot by
becoming the most advanced and intricate
organism in the world
a human being so what adventures and
knowledge await it as it begins to see
the world through the eyes of a human
being
this is it this is probably the violet
evergarden equivalent for the season you
know the cinematic production and
tearjerker with some dramatic and
profound themes about identity and
self-discovery the manga also got some
stellar reviews too so i'm extremely
excited to see how this turns out as an
anime adaptation i think that this title
won't disappoint
and ultimately will be in the running
for the best anime of the season
is to your eternity also your most
anticipated new anime of spring 2021
why or why not tell me in the comments
section below
oh and you can also share what you think
is the best upcoming new series for
spring i'll be waiting for your picks
don't forget as well i'd like to
introduce you guys to my patreon
in case you haven't been around for the
past few videos i've opened up a patreon
and your contributions will go a long
way in helping me make even better
content in the future if you're
interested check it out in the
description box below
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video expressvpn
bypass all those pesky region locks and
even browse sites not available in your
region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
here's to an amazing season
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you